[Music]
is
[Music]
okay guys i just saw alidawah he's going
to that shop
i'm going to follow him and i'm going to
question him on what he did to me
i'm going to confront him now and he's
going to answer for what he did to me
i'm following you i follow you because
you know what you did to me
you know what you did you know what you
did to me
you didn't give me tawa
okay guys welcome to this video you saw
the drama you saw the action
you saw the sick editing alhamdulillah
brothers and sisters
let's get a bit serious let's understand
the full story
who is this sister why did she approach
me
why was there such a accusation made why
was this video that was done a year and
a half ago
that was published by somebody to get
viral but it didn't
but a group of brothers uh certain
brothers who
sadly belong to a certain group who
always are known to attack the muslims
reignited this why did they do that why
did they share this information
a a accusation and allegation we're
going to talk about the severity of
slander
brothers and sisters please watch this
in full to understand the full story
how muhammad hijab plays a role in
what's happened all of this where did
this all began
so we can give it a context brother and
sister i'm going to get straight into it
inshallah
let's talk about the severity of
slander brother says this is very very
key for us yeah
it's very important because you see i do
uber once i picked up a woman from the
hospital with her colleague her friend
and all the way in the journey obviously
i can hear that conversation she was
crying and you know i was trying to
understand why is she crying why she's
so distressed
and she was saying that i can hear that
in the workplace there was a rumor going
this woman had a boyfriend
and basically in the workplace in the
hospital people were given rumors that
she
and another guy were kind of liking each
other and she was very disturbed by this
and rightly so why
because it's a slander it's not true why
are you saying something
or making it seem like somebody's done
something that they haven't
and it's big it's very very severe in
the site of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and sheikh saleh has got a whole book on
jurisprudence
about slander how you deal with it and
the person that does it what's the
punishment
islamically the punishment is 80 lashes
yes
80 lashes brothers and sisters and this
has to be done publicly
and that person's testimony should never
be taken and in order for it to be
executed the person that they slandered
has to be brought forth and the
permission has to be asked
do you forgive them or should we punish
them etc yeah
in my specific instance yeah with this
situation happening
me personally i would personally want
this
person um whipped why because it's my
right
because i'm i'm a public figure not that
i'm anything special but i'm in the
scene
to damage my reputation it's not me it's
not about me you're making islam
and a person who's a muslim somebody
who's you know doing dawah
and you're damaging the whole tower so
it's not something minou and it's also
that should be forgiven it should be
done
and dealt with severely however now
me personally i've done a video three
four years ago where a
french girl in france in france was
accused there was a video going about
that seemed like it was her
and she was being accused of fornicating
and you know what this girl did she
threw herself out the window and killed
herself
i had to do a documentary traveling to
france going to the ghettos
being chased by road guys yeah because
we wanted to cover to what happened to
the sister
to even build a water world for sadhaka
jardia
because it was it was a slander and we
was questioning people
about the video and they were like some
people were like yeah it was her and i'm
thinking what do you mean it was her but
how are you saying that so casually
you are the reason why this girl killed
herself and you're here telling me
that and the videos that you can see the
video above and sisters that i did you
can see it for yourself
and it was sad a person took their life
because of this and we're going to come
to surah nur where allah said now
revelation to defend
her the same brothers who are
spreading this video as a father against
me who attacked the rafidah
yes certain extreme shia groups yeah who
accused the prophet its wife peace be
upon him
and they're falling into the same thing
of slandering a believer just as they
did
yeah so i went there and did that
documentary why to emphasize on it
recently there's been another case i
cannot remember the name of the sister
in palestine
a rumor was spread about her and this
rumor
caused her to be killed can you imagine
these people standing in front of
under their judgment the blood of a
muslim is more dearer than the kaaba
and you played a role in that innocent
sister
who was looking to get married you
accused and standed her that she
got killed and many people lose their
life
or destroy them mentally psychologically
of the lie
that you're spreading let's go to surah
nur brothers and sisters allah says in
the quran and those who accuse chaste
woman
and do not produce four witnesses
because a woman's dignity is
more it's it's bigger than a man's
because it's miracles
you shouldn't stand above male 1 or
females but here and those who accuse
chased women and then do not produce for
witnesses
lash them with 80 lashes
and do not accept from them testimony
ever after and those are definitely
disobedient
except for those who repent thereafter
and return
and and reform for indeed allah is
forgiven merciful
and then allah says indeed those who
came with the falsehood
are a group amongst you yeah there was
uh the munafikun yeah the monafix
do you not think it is bad for you
rather it is good for you for every
person among them is what punishment he
has earned from the sin
and he took upon himself the greater
portion thereof for him
is a greater punishment why when you
heard it did not believe in men and
believe in one think good of one another
and say
this is an obvious falsehood not like
those who gossip and yeah you know let's
find something with it
why did they who islam did not produce
four witnesses and why they
and when they did not produce the
witnesses then it is they in the sight
of allah who are lies
and if it had not been for the favor of
allah upon you is mercy in this one and
hereafter you would have been touched
for that
a lie in which you are involved in a
great punishment so brother says allah
was talking about the severity
why when the believing men and women
heard it didn't say you know what no no
we stay we free ourselves from what
you're saying
and instead used it use it for your own
purposes or stand or whatever it may be
why
because you wanted to marry that girl
and you know somebody else marrying so
you spend the standard i was a bit la
when different people use it for
different reasons which we're going to
come to who is this girl brothers and
sisters
let's get into it yeah and we'll come to
where this all began from and how it was
used yeah so a certain brother who has a
problem with hijab and myself but
specifically hijab
um he's used this to slander us uh
slander me yeah
now this sister i was one day a
speaker's corner
and i was walking around and i came
across a group of sisters
there was a somali sister and there was
a blonde sister in that video you can
see and both of them can witness and
vouch
for what happened yeah they both can
vouch for it yeah
i was there and i saw a fake ex-muslim
as usual
lying that i was a muslim before so i
was listening to the conversation to
challenger
yeah why defend the team of allah
because you know this is lying
so i was standing there there was a
group of sisters and this sister and
then a car was standing there
this system in a car i saw her in maybe
one or two occasions in the park
yeah with a a brother then they won't
marry but i would just
see them i don't know the connection
maybe they weren't i don't know i assume
the best maybe they might i don't know
but
i would see them yeah that's one
two times i've seen her so all i see is
she's look behind me goes get away from
me
so i'm looking at her and i'm thinking
like
is she talking to me like i'm looking
around here and while i believe allah is
my witness if i'm lying
yeah and if i am lying those who are
spreading this video
we take an oath for allah may allah
destroy the one that's lying
yeah let's let's do that openly i've got
no problem let's do that inshallah
if you are going to share that video and
trying to insinuate that i did something
to the sister of the villa
shame on you
there is not a single woman a single
girl that can say that i
ever approached them or
or invited them for zina or any uh i
would have been
other actions ever if there is anyone
out there come out
come out and expose me i'm telling you
come out and expose me i'll give you
full permission
you know what i will put it on my
channel i will put it on my channel
bring the evidences forth and i'll do it
alhamdulillah i'm not a hypocrite
i'm not someone that says something that
does opposite yes i'm weak
yes i might fall into certain sins ah
but this never
inshallah may allah protect and preserve
me from this from the fitnah of women
yeah
so i was looking i'm thinking like
sister are you talking to me
she goes yeah i'm talking to you get
away from me start thinking like
i'm baffled like are you okay like what
what's your problem
i said i'm here to listen to this
conversation she stopped bugging out
no get away from me i don't think what
the hell is going on
now when it was happening there was a
specific guy in speaker's corner
who had problems with me he comes up
with a camera of nowhere
so i'm thinking about hold on a second
bravo how is this guy
just randomly you know sorry and just
came so i was thinking that's why i said
to him
why are you recording like is is this
all planned yeah
so when she started doing that i said
hold on a second sister i told the
brother to go and get the other brothers
with the main channels i said bring your
cameras here
they brought their cameras they didn't
release here they brought him i said
sister
please tell the camera i'm giving you
permission what i did to you
expose me i'm giving you permission
you've come now you've making these
allegations
what you've done what you've done etc
here's the cameras
tell them after don't give me permission
tell them yeah
no i'm not one second how are you making
allegations
screaming shouting but you're not so
brothers and sisters in our daughter we
have a lot of enemies
i've got their flesh from isis from
rafidah extreme rough this this footage
where the guy
rafter goes i'm going to cut your head
off yeah isis have threatened me that
certain police officers came to give me
osmond warning yeah
that's what's called osmond warning yeah
meaning that they have to buy law
yeah that somebody's fret in your life
the far right
yeah the far right have gone to a
telephone box and said death threats
i've got their first variety of other
people yeah and also for example these
uh certain other cult yeah this group of
uh individual uh brothers espops who
always attack the muslims yeah
that's why hijab had a problem with them
so i always get this so
any of these guys can send this send
send this girl because i don't know who
she is
i have no idea who she is yeah well i
have no idea i'm thinking
is there a connection with a marriage
documentary has there been any instance
where i was getting to know a sister for
marriage
didn't work out she's got grudges and i
wouldn't believe i've never done dating
or something i would be like i'm
thinking what what is it
so we don't know we're still
investigating the marriage documentary
we might find out
now let's go to brothers and sisters
where
all this began why did this certain
brother who comes to the speaker who
comes to the speaker's corner
why did he find the need to use this
because of his dispute with us and
specifically muhammad hijab
now why did he find the need to share
this video because now what you're doing
is you're planting
doubt and this is exactly what a brother
i used to work with did
he start releasing videos after i
started working with him same pattern
with these guys they're very similar to
each other very simple
yeah kind of releasing videos of
these shady tower characters
impregnating girls
leaving how the billah and the way he
did it
and he was saying oh this these brothers
i used to work with bob in the darwin
used to work with it was me
who was it that who you pointing at i
was
making these false allegations and kind
of some people were saying brother ali
like i thought he's talking about you
and one like they don't fail the
subhanallah just because their ego gets
hurt
and just because we do videos and trying
to advise and refute them
yet on the points that stop attacking
muslims and stop calling everyone they
innovate innovative
innovator just because of that and you
don't like it and your ego gets hurt
what you do you drop your understanding
to a level of slandering
slander of adultery sinner
fear of surprise so the same thing
happened before so
now why did this brother do this
brothers and sisters
it's all started it all started
one day like we had this instance with a
specific brother
he does doubt we have no problem with
him in the park you would never see
us having a problem with prophethood but
have been a problem with brother hashem
but
having a problem with me me having a
problem with hijab he's not having a
problem with another brother
we all go and eat together we're right
all the brothers are cool with each
other except
this group of brothers since they've
come to the park while
they they do they they they they
associate themselves with us
if they're doing darwin we come into the
video it's like they're gonna have a
heart attack like oh
and like they have this and this is the
reason why they always attack muslims
always attack muslims so they don't come
next to us they don't eat with us
yes they give salam even that is stopped
now now they treat us like enemies they
give salaam to the christians the
mushrikeen yeah
they give salam to them people who
insult the prophet yeah will give you
good excuses they give them good excuses
but when it comes to us we give them
salam
i wouldn't be allah there was one
brother uh in them
yeah i forgot his name yeah beautiful
brother i used to talk to him
i gave him salam allah he looked at me
like i'm the dirt of this earth and this
is exactly how i was made to feel with
the other brother i used to work with
so you can see how they're so
brainwashed that wallahi what is me and
hijab doing
we're trying to defend the religion of
allah hijab destroy david with the
biggest enemy this
filth of this earth he was speaking ill
of our prophet
hijab defends the owner of a believer
when ahmed got attacked in the park
what hijab did i believe he was right
how he was hijacked
but i disagree with that hijab is always
there to defend the honor of a believer
always defend the honor of a believer
yeah while these guys
didn't do nothing not only that they
attacked ahmed
they punched ahmed in the face and we've
got another video that's going to come
out in black dunya's channel
you're going to see how ahmed i
interviewed him he got punched in the
face
and i didn't want to release that video
because the fitna calm down now with
this video of accusation
that video is going to be released
you're going to see and hear it from
ahmed how he was punched in the face
by this group of brothers and was it
only ahmed they got punched in their
face
nope
was attacked a brother in the prophet's
masjid was slapped
i was physically going to get attacked
they didn't release that footage
yeah so this is where this all begins
from and i'm going to tell you so you
would understand why they shared this
video
one day this brother he's doing doubt to
the christians i'm listening to him
he's making points valid points etc but
there's something crucial that it's very
simple that can be done
it's a tough see in the top see it that
we can destroy the claim of the
christian claiming that we can force
people to accept islam very basic
but it didn't come to his mind i was
waiting and i said let me help him it's
my brother
i differ with him he treats me hard
she's been rude to me he's invited me to
his house he's been good to me as well
sometimes let's be just here
but i said let me help him all i did is
get my ipad and i said aki
use it the guy's face color change
uncomfortable
i don't know why because he seems to me
i'm a jihad yeah i'm ignorant he's very
knowledgeable yeah
so he felt i think his ego got hurt
because
i was helping him and he deals me to be
an innovator
so all i did was help him in the debate
against the christian that's all i did i
said aki there you go
yeah and what he did was he started
after that video when the christchurch
attack happened he done a video refuting
me
this alidawah he's a test of innovators
and i'm thinking bruv
what did i do to you what have i done to
you
you would always call me names and etc
and stuff and i ignored you
and i assumed the best as a brother i
didn't want fitna in the park now you've
come to a video doing publicly i said no
enough is enough
yeah we said enough is enough so what we
did is we said
let's clarify our position and we said
look if you're going to be like that
then we'll
we'll retaliate it all started from
their brothers and sisters
and from there onwards we was getting
attacked uh they were they were doing
videos against us and then what hijab
done is he dropped
this time they stopped attacking hijab
yeah start attacking the job calling him
names he's this he's that
so he just said look you've been quiet
we've got a lot to expose him you guys
we have him for the sake of allah
so now that you're doing this hold on a
second so what hijab did was this
hijab went and said let's research into
these people what are they doing yeah
the hypocrisy the hypocrisy they have
now
these guys hypocrisy is unreal this same
brother his
teacher his so-called teacher yad
yeah accused another guy who was a
literal evil doer isis
he was isis terrorist yeah and i'm not
using that connotation they use are
muslims yeah terrorism has all kinds of
backgrounds
the one who carried the london bridge
attacks if i'm mistaken here
he was being accused of committing zinna
yeah committing
zinna by this uh by the newspapers yeah
now what he did is evil we're not here
to defend him but if there's something
that's wrongly attributed
to him we're defending what's being
attributed to him wrongly we're not
defending the guy the guy what he did
was wrong against islam
haram this guy goes and accuses him and
says yeah he used to commit zina how was
the bill
and you guys are talking about the quran
the sunnah 24 7
how are you casually accusing the
believer of zinna
then i'm thinking to myself hold on a
second this brother's teacher is this
guy
so it seems very clear the accusation of
sinner where it comes from because his
teacher does it
his teacher accuses people of zinna
where you need to bring four witnesses
or you get lashed
in public above lashed lashed you get
humiliated
you know testimony never gets accepted
so so now i'm thinking ah this makes
sense so now
this guy does the same thing insinuating
sharing this video again
yeah because he has a problem with hijab
because there's a problem of hijab
he shares this video trying to show oh
look your boy ali dawa look what sisters
are you know accusing him and you're not
doing nothing about it
i wouldn't be that let's say argument
say hijab was wrong what you did let's
suppose argument's sake
is that right for you to accuse and
slander me and insinuate that i
did something to the sister i was a bit
allah do you not have no shame
have some shame why you like have some
shame i know people don't believe this i
know myself well
i know myself what's sad is that you're
dropping to that level
i don't believe hijab was wrong he
brought evidences he bought evidences
that you guys get prevent money
the same money you get from the
government prevent is
an organization a body of the government
that always attacks muslims
marginalizes them and always you know
profiles them yeah and you guys get
money from them
you get funded by them why two you're
fighting against extremism
doing what attacking believers attacking
muslims calling them names
like i don't go to that level i could
have started video like you guys and say
you're a donkey
you're a camel you turn into a zoo
you're a zebra you're a hypopotamus
you're a dinosaur
i'm not going to do that well he's not
the character of the prophet peace be
upon him and i try my best
to have that and you guys are believers
i'm not going to come here call you
names
you're a donkey you're this you're that
i'm not going to do that i'm not going
to call you names
there's brothers in your group well i
give them salam every time i see them
and they look at me like i'm piece of
dirt not all of them some of them they
treat me good they're good to me
may allah bless them they're not that
brainwashed to that level yeah
and you're saying this is the sunnah how
you treat us muslims who are defending
that we're trying to defend one of the
believer
and all you're doing is attacking
believers and it made sense when you get
money you guys
as pubs yeah you guys know what i'm
talking about s pubs
who have been attacking muslims shaykh
tahir dwight
came to your teacher your teacher who's
not even
that knowledgeable he came to your
teacher he came to your teacher
and he said what's your problem with
shaykh why is he done to you
he couldn't say nothing he had nothing
if this is not jealousy and envy what is
it
somebody who's been praised by the
scholars which we believe is a salafi
yeah and this word has been hijacked by
these groups
yeah somebody who's balanced
yeah these people who you have slandered
and allah humiliated you at the hands of
a mushrik a christian
paper boy paper boy put you in your
place
here in this video above and watch this
video and you see in this video
how this guy who's slandering me yeah
who's slandering me
who was humiliated because this guy's
caught in shack
and he said he's a chicken look how
allah humiliated that you had to run
away like a chicken when he asked your
qualifications
yeah when he asked your qualifications
you keep attacking hijab
attacking all the muslims and what
happened when he asked you for your
qualifications
you did a runner just as when you saw
him of the munir
you did a left turn when real people of
knowledge came oh you don't want to know
and you have no qualifications you have
no qualifications to do
they call people innovators people of
the hellfire you have no qualifications
and you do that and look how allah
immediately watch this video bob and
sisters
this is a life he yeah he's alive he's
an american national israel
and an american nationalist he's an
american national
who studied at the university of medina
in saudi arabia
right so he's no he's not qualified
because right
so he's like chicken to him what's your
qualification okay
okay
i just want that one question because
i'm going to show you bro bro what he
said no no i just want to
know just what are your qualifications
right so over their bone sisters
this brother just because i helped him
in a debate his ego got hurt he attacked
us attacked hijab so hijab went and did
some research
he bought evidence he brought like just
muslims
it's a testimony yeah and what did they
do they got upset
oh you're slandering your line oh
subhanallah when you guys have been
attacking
muslims attacking them continuously for
no reason
but because you believe them to be
innovators when you're not even
qualified
yourself your teacher who are these
people what is your qualifications
please give us your qualification you
always say refer to the people of
knowledge but
who are you where did you study
you think you say
don't forget shaytan was the most
knowledgeable he worshiped allah
everywhere
his knowledge didn't save him because he
was arrogant
i can cure my problem with knowledge
america i'm ignorant well there's a cure
for my ignorance
i study hamdulillah yeah not study the
way you want me to um study my teachers
yeah and you can see from my videos i've
ever done a step up done a mistake in
akita
show me once once once one video the
person that you call jay is no problem
have i ever done a mistake never these
terms these words
can do they don't bother me yeah ali
needs dawah one lion in his thought he
spoke the hug
and it's these statements that keep me
humble and keep me i'm in my place
i stick to my lane but someone like you
who is not qualified
doing tab d how are you doing this
you're not qualified your teacher is not
qualified
you i believe you are more qualified
together
you know more than them and even what
you know it doesn't benefit you because
you become arrogant
yeah you look down at people talk down
against people
my mata is very clear let's go back to
the people allah
should fight then make sesame between
the two but if one of them oppressed
other then fight against the one that
oppresses until it returns to the
ordinance
of allah and if it and if it returns
then make settlement between them in
justice and act
justly indeed indeed allah loves those
who act justly believes the believers
are about brothers so make sentiment
between your brothers and fear allah
that you may receive mercy why we treat
you guys like brothers
when i see them i try to give them salam
but were like they oppressed me like the
brother i used to work with before
stop giving me salam start calling me
names yeah is this from the sunnah
is this from the salaf treating your
brothers like that
is this from salah please tell me this
is from the salah yeah giving greeting
greeting people who insult the prophet
grieving the christians and the jews
there's no problem i agree with them as
well but when it comes to your buffer
you humiliate your core names donkey
this that he needs that uh
i have to invite your self righteous
what will i feel allah remember shaytan
remember shaytan the most righteous man
his righteousness and his knowledge did
not benefit him because he had arrogance
in his heart
and allah says all you have believed let
not a people ridicule another people
perhaps they may be better than them
subhanallah look at this
no let the woman ridiculous other women
perhaps they may be better than them
and do not insult one another and do not
call each other by offensive nicknames
rich is the name of disobedience after
one's faith and whoever does not repent
then it is those who are the wrongdoers
all you have believed avoid much
negative assumptions
the slander that you are trying to
spread about me with that sister
yeah indeed assumption is a sin and do
not spy or back by each other
would one of you like to eat the flesh
of his brother when he's dead you would
detest it
and fear allah indeed allah is accepting
repentance and merciful
brothers and sisters i want to end on
this note i'm not here and
well it's not in my character and i try
my best i'm not trying to act super
righteously here
i don't like calling names yeah i see
these people as my brother still
the brother the brother that i used to
work with and people amongst him who
used to call me names
and these brothers well he has a reverb
brother
and a lot of reavers when they come to
the dean they leave why
because of this disgusting vile attitude
if i wasn't strong i would have felt
oppressed
and think you know what forget this
religion and wallahi this is what a lot
of people do
and you can blame them are emotional
reasons like some people look i i have
got some like emotional reasons i have
got some as well
don't get twisted but i'm talking about
sometimes when you're oppressing a
muslim
ridiculing them calling them names for
what
because you deemed their innovator but
who are you
so brothers and sisters allah's kalam is
clear and allah sent surah nur to defend
the owner of a believer
and inshallah this prophet repents he
has to do public repentance
because this matter is going to go to
the ulama we're going to go to the
scholars we're going to go to scholars
for two things and i challenge them
i challenge both of these ones but i
used to work within them they're both
very similar
ones as puppet ones s pop reject one
tries to be like them yeah once when i
suppose s but reject yeah
we go to the museum
i'm going to go to them for two things
are these people who's qualified to do
table and number two spreading
information and this video about me that
i would be like i did something to the
sister this is slander
and these are going to be question don't
think look we we know these scholars
we're going to go to them
we're going to ask them questions yeah
and you're going to be in trouble now
because you have to publicly repent
like your teacher abu iyad who accuse
another believer who's dead
of zina and you guys are the same guys
who
boycotted one of your teachers you had
26 of them all of them are innovative
innovations you're left with two three
uh shahman had been had if i'm not
mistaken here that he accused somebody
of committing they not you boycotted him
how did he do that and you guys have
seen like hypocrisy
you you you say oh no he's done this
anyway that was wrong okay if you claim
it's wrong okay
then you're doing the same thing
accusing people and you're the same
person and look how they mock the issue
of dinner they're so light for them i
can remember when we had this dispute he
came and said to me
oh go and do your videos of zina how was
the bill allah says
don't even come near it and you're
mocking it like hey go go
it's not me saying uh go and do
reminders about tawheed and [ __ ]
you're mocking what allah has legislated
don't go near it and i'm doing videos to
encourage the youngsters to stay away
from and you're mocking me go do videos
on
zina that's why it makes sense and you
mocking the issue of sinner your teacher
accusing other people of zinna and now
you're doing the same why because you
have a dispute with us
specifically hijab well hijab or
evidences watch the videos brothers and
sisters
these guys get paid by prevent yes
they get paid by prevent a body that
attacks muslims and these guys have
attacked muslims
myself ahmed who got punched in the face
two three years ago when i used to study
with him he was grabbed by the colors
at the uh another baba in the masjid abu
made me from the mistaken
he was slapped in his face in the masjid
can you believe it
the prophet peace be upon him and a few
other instances i cannot remember yeah
they always attack muslims you need to
ask yourself a question getting paid by
prevent
who attack who always attack muslims and
then these guys always attack muslims
we need to ask ourselves questions who
are these people why are they doing this
why do they have a million pounds in
their account
so brothers and sisters the story here
is this
that because of personal grudges and ego
i was brought
to seem like i did something to the
sister and allahi
we ask i would challenge him let's meet
in public
and take the curse of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala that if you're saying
what you said and don't come and then
you start panicking and releasing the
video straight away after we did a sick
video yeah the mother did a sick edit
the edit got you shook when you saw it
like
bro like i need to do it you you know
our editor our editor got you shook
yeah when you saw him editing you said
yo fam i need to do i need to go and do
a clarification video
i didn't mean that yeah you panicked
yeah you panicked
yeah you did a clarification video oh i
didn't mean that no
if there's a video going imagine if i
did that to you there's some sister
accusing you and i can't play the video
and i go look i'm not seeing he did that
brother what are you planting in the
people's minds
just like the buffer i used to work with
yeah he did the same thing
show you the characters and that was it
fear allah because you're spreading this
like it is true and you have no evidence
some sister coming and accusing me who
are you
but maybe in the match documentary we
might make a connection we're doing some
research who was this sister
why was she so upset with me brothers
and sisters insha allah may allah bless
you guys for watching this story it was
wrong but we had to give you a context
we asked his brothers to feel
subhanallah and come to the correct path
inshallah
which is the prophet muhammad saying
your innovator we're just saying that
come
and brother and sisters this cult-like
mentality there's a whole pdf
written and shaken has things in there
as well
watch and read it i'm gonna download the
pdf how these cult members
how if you're against them they're
they're the loyalty is if you're with
them they're with you if you're against
them they're against you
this is a cult mentality brother sisters
and the salaf
using the word salafi the seller for
free from this behavior well lie they're
free
the salaf were balanced alhamdulillah
not extreme everyone's an innovator
so may allah bless you guys brother
sisters forgive me for making this so
long
this is the context power of the
documentary is going to be mud
we're going to be destroying haram
relationships and yes
this brother who mocked me for talking
about zina while i'm not going to stop
off wage war against dinner and
inshallah in the power of documentary
bombing sisters we're going to show you
the damages and how you should break it
up in your haram relationship
and pursue the right way the halal pure
way
of getting married inshallah and
inshallah sisters part one of
documentaries nearly ready
may allah bless you guys for watching it
until next time share this with your
friends and family
and defend the believer of honor the
honor of believe above and sisters
if anybody has this negative assumption
clarify with them inshallah um which i
hided that
only people of fitna would believe this
until next time
sorry i've said that ten times assalamu
alaikum what happened tonight
and the only thing i did to the sister
was
i didn't reach the marriage documentary